we want to welcome back Donna Brazile
the book is called hacks - the inside
story of the break-ins and breakdowns
that put Donald Trump in the White House
how's your week been it's been great
it's been exciting I've heard from
friends as well as people who wanted to
not only encouraged me to tell my story
but they also wanted to know more about
the hacking so it's been an interesting
week we've seen a lot of interviews
we're glad we can take a step back and
spend some time to talk about the book
but I want to get your reaction from
some Republicans including rubbing milk
from the Hillary Clinton campaign this
is what he said on CNN this past week
when the DNC approached both campaigns
about a joint fundraising agreement they
were broke they weren't going to make
payroll they were not going to be able
to transfer down money to the state
parties to keep them operational they
were in a really bad place both the
Sanders campaign and the Clinton
campaign sign joint fundraising
agreement so we both thought it was a
good thing to sign up for the only
difference was Sanders didn't raise any
money in and we did the DNC appeal
Sanders was raising money in it I mean
you guys had big big money donors
Sanders was getting more donations from
from you know individuals and and
smaller donations no well and that would
have been great it would have been great
for the DNC to raise jointly with him
Hillary turned over her email lists to
the DNC after the election was over so
it's really important for those low
dollar donors to be to be part of the
DNC process but the the DNC came to our
campaign and said we need help we you
know we were not prepared for the
general election we created the memo of
understanding that was there it wasn't
about the primary election and as
Brianna said we were very frustrated
with the DNC many times the idea that we
had any control over there is pretty
laughable right but they put guard rails
in about how the money that we raised
needed to be focused on the general
election activities that were really
going to matter Donna Brazile your
reaction to the Clinton campaign chair
Robbie milk last week on CNN well first
of all Robbie is absolutely right the
DNC was broke where Robbie and I
disagree is that the DNC which nominated
Secretary Clinton should have been
independent it should not have received
those Reid
sources that would later be construed as
the DNC tilt into one side the fact is
is that Secretary Clinton won she won
the she won the primary she had four
million more votes and it's almost like
a landslide when you look at the the
outcome of the election but the truth is
is that the DNC should have been free to
spend its own resources and as I've
stated in a book which I think is it's
important for people in the future those
are those who will lead to the
Democratic Party before a nominee is
selected no one should take control of
any of the functions of the DNC you had
a phone conversation with Hillary
Clinton you write about it in the book
the election was in November she called
you in February she called me I'm sure
because what we talked about the future
of the Democratic Party
she called me three months later I can
assume that given what had happened in
the election what was going on Secretary
Clinton had a long list of people to
call including donors supporters
volunteers state party leaders and and
of course members of Congress the
President of the United States and you
know somewhere along that list Donna
Brazile but it's great I still admire
her I think she is a phenomenal woman I
think the campaign that Robbie and
others managed fell short
and that's why I wrote this book I I
wanted to write my own postmortem
Robby Mook and others in the Clinton
campaign of free to write their
postmortem what they're not free to do
is is to denigrate the DNC
destroy the DNC others destroy any
entity that is there to help elect
Americans from across the landscape well
as you know they wrote a letter and I
want to just read part of it we were
shocked to learn the news the Donna
Brazile actively considered overturning
the will of the Democratic voters by
attempting to replace Hillary Clinton
and Tim Kaine it is particularly
troubling and puzzling that she would
seemingly buy into the false Russian
fueled propaganda and about our
candidates health Donna came in to take
over the DNC at a very difficult time we
were grateful for her doing so but we do
not recognize the campaign she portrays
in the book finally we are pretty tired
of people who were not part of our
campaign telling the world what it was
like to be on the inside we loved our
candidate and each other
and remain an honor to have been part of
the effort to make Hillary Clinton the
45th president and I appreciate the last
part of excuse me the last part of that
letter no one worked as hard as I did I
traveled across this country to support
and and help elect the first female
president someone I've known for over 30
years
my again my book hacks is about the the
break-ins and breakdowns that led to the
election of Donald Trump and I gave an
assessment of how the Democratic Party
fell short of his mission in large part
because we did not have the resources I
believed we needed to to win in those
states that that Donald Trump was able
to win they share with you this headline
from the New York Times a conversation
that the President had with Vladimir
Putin yes his denial of Russian
interference in the elections are
sincere the president saying I believe
him
extremely disappointed first of all mr.
president this was an attack on our
country this was attack on our democracy
our election system and more importantly
this was an active campaign to discredit
the nominee of the Democratic Party to
destroy the Democratic National
Committee and to sow discord between
ordinary citizens the fact that we're
now learning about the investment that
the Russians made in our social media
platforms the fact that we're not even
working to improve or be prepared in
2018 for further foreign interference be
it from Russia or from any other nation
I think the president needs to
acknowledge what 17 agencies have said
and what many Americans now have come to
know that Russia did interfere in meddle
with our election well here's what the
president said in Vietnam will show that
and get your reaction what I said I'm
surprised that there's any conflict on
this what I said there's that I believe
he believes that and that's very
important for somebody to believe I
believe that he feels that he and Russia
did not meddle in the election as to
whether I believe it or not I'm with our
agencies especially as currently
constituted with their leadership I
believe in our intelligent
these are intelligence agencies I've
worked with them very strongly there
weren't seventeen as was previously
reported there were actually four but
they were saying there was 17 there were
actually four but as currently led by
fine people I believe very much in our
intelligence agencies now at the same
time I want to be able because I think
it's very important to get along with
Russia to get along with China to get
along with Vietnam to get along with
lots of countries because we have a lot
of things we have to sell and frankly
Russia and China in particular can help
us with the North Korea problem which is
one of our truly great problems so I'm
not looking to stand and start arguing
with somebody when this report is all
around and cameras recording and seeing
our conversation I think was very
obvious to everybody I believe that
President Putin really feels and he
feels strongly that he did not meddle in
our election Donna Brazile the president
in vietnam yesterday he is in the
philippines this morning your reaction
well again I'm disappointed at the
president when we learned at the DNC and
of course we didn't learn it right away
because it took time for it to however
get to the the right leadership within
the party but when we learned that there
was Russian malware and spyware that
they had been in our system for well
over you know 10 months to a year that
they had and not just stolen emails but
they also were they were still in
research data they were stealing many of
our technology tools this was confirmed
not just by one agency but this was
confirmed by 17 intelligence agencies
that the Russians were indeed involved
in our system I'm disappointed that the
president has not taken this as
seriously as it should be when I
received my briefing from a federal
agency but my first reaction Steve was
to go straight to the Pentagon I said
why should I go back to the DNC
the DNC is under attack and and this was
a cyber espionage campaign that sought
as I mentioned to discredit and destroy
our nominee Hillary
Clinton that meddled in our election
systems that metal without data it
wasn't just the DNC was a d-triple-c the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee and I would hope that the
president would listen to the
intelligence agencies look I concluded
after I was briefed that something was
going on that they weren't just going in
our email box a trove of emails of over
a hundred staffers they were looking for
information that could discredit Hillary
Clinton discredit Bernie Sanders and and
so in my judgment the the Russians did
interfere and meddle in our election our
guest is donna Brazile the former head
of the Democratic National Committee and
longtime Democratic Party strategist she
ran the Al Gore campaign our phone lines
are open we'll get to your calls in just
a moment two parts from the book I want
to ask you about first you write the
following this election broke all the
rules and destroyed the tradition of
civility as a country we ask these
fundamental questions who are we what do
we value can we find a way to trust
again
and not just see each other as partisan
enemies I believe one of the reasons why
the Russians were successful and Medlin
and interfere in our election is because
we're so polarized during the time in
which the hackin was occurring I kept
reaching out to my Republican
counterparts I kept saying help us don't
allow the the the spyware and the male
malware to just to destroy our party the
Democratic National Committee next year
will celebrate a hundred and seventy
years and I was concerned also about the
Republicans I was concerned that their
database may be destroyed and I kept
warning them what we were being told
about the apt 28 apt 29 known as cozy
bear and then fancy bear we found some
other bears and some wolves - but I was
concerned enough about our country as an
American that I warned the Republicans
of what was happening to the Democrats
so that if by chance they were being
attacked the steps we were taken to get
rid of these and remediate the the
Russian interference in our system and
you write in the book how all of this in
the staff of the DNC located not just
just a few blocks and where we are and
also the the murder of Seth rich how did
all of that play into this well let me
just say this and I have to be very
careful when I talk about Seth Seth Seth
worked at the DNC
he was a great loyal dedicated staff
person he worked in the Voting Rights
Division as the vice chair for civic
engagement and voter participation Seth
was one of the two people that worked in
my area and let me just tell you his
murder was we took it seriously we cried
for days we mourn the loss of not just
our colleague but a friend and so Seth
was murdered on July 10th I became chair
on July 24th in between those two weeks
we saw emails of staff people being
leaked those staff members came under
harassment they started getting threats
they started getting bombarded with
emails from trolls and box we didn't
know who was setting our house on fire
but at a time we were mourning the loss
of a colleague people on staff were
harassed I have to tell you this because
I believe fundamentally that the staff
of the DNC they were the bravest people
I will ever ever get to know because
I've never served them more like my
father but they were brave they came to
work each and every day despite the fact
that they were getting death threats
that the building itself was getting
constantly threatened people were just
protesting because they had read
selectively emails and leaks that were
designed to sow discord and to turn the
DNC against the DNC that's what happened
last year let's get to your phone calls
Carol is joining us Tyler Texas you're
on the air with Donna Brazile her new
book is titled hax good morning Carol hi
Carol yes yes good morning I have a
couple questions that I like to ask and
the first one is what in the world would
make Don Brazil think that Hillary
Clinton is not capable of answering
questions during the debate I saw those
questions she gave tour and that's
ridiculous
Hillary Clinton is about the smartest
politician on the planet and those
answers to most all question
and so what was her motive for that and
I'm ashamed I used to respect her that's
over and to be loyal for any of
Democrats to be loyal to Bernie Sanders
he should marry one on the Democratic
ticket he wasn't a Democrat before he's
not one now Carole thank you for the
call and you're right about this in the
book
absolutely look Carol I'm sorry I
disappointed you but let me just say
this and Steve people confused a fact or
they actually say they forget the fact
that his vice chair the Democratic
National Committee I was on the enormous
pressure like many of the other offices
to expand the number of debates and town
halls etc and what I did and I
apologized what later because people
only saw that what Rick WikiLeaks and
others wanted you to see they didn't see
all of my emails this was John Podesta
see meals what they saw was me
supposedly given Hillary questions
provided by CNN and what I've tried to
tell people is that CNN did not share
questions with me period that's it
period but what did in fact occur during
that time when we expanded the number of
debates and town halls they said I
wanted to give both candidates in fact
when martin O'Malley was in the race and
Martin did he was one of the people who
pressured us to get more debates I
wanted to give them hats up first we
were about to talk about issues that
people of color were concerned about we
wanted to talk about the death penalty
we wanted to talk about the Flint water
crisis in Flint that was another debate
that we got expanded as CNN was have
beneficiary amenities debates but yes I
gave both candidates heads-up that we
were going to discuss topics of concerns
and black life matters people call in
others because for the first time in the
democratic party process by the by the
middle of March we had not discussed any
of these issues related to people of
color their economic circumstances the
criminal justice systems the things that
people cared about so that's the way I
operate it and you know I also write in
a book that every Saturday before I went
on a Sunday show I reached out to the
Republicans so I guess miss Carol is
upset with that but I don't know the
Republican Party process I know the
Democratic party process and so I would
reach out to Sean spike so before he
became press secretary and say Sean
what's happening
Obachan said I reached out to Rick Tyler
what's happening with your candidate
Alice dirt wet and Anna Navarro I
reached out to everybody because I am
the person that I've always been
somebody who is fair somebody who wants
to get the facts and somebody who is
willing to engage more people in the
process were you surprised at CNN cut
their ties with you know Donna cut might
I cut the ties I'm not surprised that
they have continued to attack me but I
cut ties you know why I cut ties because
I got home that night and I could not
find the evidence that they were asking
me to prove and because I could not find
that because I could not find those
emails I told them let's let it go let
it go because I'll take it they won the
proud a statement but I thought that's
not the way I would handle it I have
been I have been with seeing it for 14
years I loved seeing and by the way many
members of my family some of them who
were rescued but it was because CNN
allowed me to use that platform to say
to the American people we got to help
the people down in Louisiana so I would
hope that people would look at this show
this morning and say Donna still loves
seeing it I watched CNN I still I mean
Anderson is still my boo I mean I mean I
be his you know boo boo but he's still
my boo and Don Lemon is my brother from
Louisiana but I want to go back and
address one issue that you didn't give
me an opportunity to address or I should
say I talk too much
Hillary Clinton I dropped everything to
become the chair to Democratic National
Committee for the second time in my
adult life I have 21 election cycles 11
presidential plus 21 every offseason
three weeks ago I was in Northern
Virginia canvass for a candidate who
became the first Asian American woman to
be elected to the House delegates I
raise money for them if Hillary called
me on a Sunday and say done I need you
to drop everything and go and walk the
streets I would do it I did the same for
President Obama and I did it for
everyone else when it came time for me
to answer the many people who were
calling me not just reporters but also
members of the party who were concerned
about her
health it was my job as chair the
Charter stipulates that my job as chair
to confer with other Democratic leaders
and all I had to do I had to think about
this this [ __ ] this video went viral
so the notion that I took some message
from the Russians please after being a
Benna I've been both hacked by the
Chinese as a member OPM staffer and now
the Russians so I'm not trying to take
talking points from anybody in fact I
don't even take Democratic talking
points but I am trying to explain how
the country was hacked and how in 2018
they might come back and just and try to
destroy us again one quick follow-up
with regard to CNN because Jake Tapper
was very critical of you yes what was
your reaction I respect Jake I saw Jake
right before Rosh Hashana a few months
ago and I respect Jake Tapper but I said
in the book that Jake I'm no journalist
I am a partisan with a point of view
that is why CNN hired me to be a
partisan and the notion that I'm I'm
going to get pressure from CNN to
produce more debates in town halls and I
have all of those emails but but when my
email or my so-called email was leaked
and then put out to destroy me which is
fine I mean that's game that's a game
but when CNN did the POW on I say a
whole type let's let's we can explain
how this process work because I know how
this process work but it's okay because
guess what I am a woman of faith I have
my I have my god I have my great friends
and my family my beautiful family and
they will stand by me including many
Democrats you're one of how many I'm the
third of nine back to your phone calls
Barbara New York City independent line
with Donna Brazile hi Barbara hi good
morning miss Brazil good morning Steve
I'm miss Brazil I called to say thank
you for writing your book we need to
know what's going on and how these
parties operate so I'm very appreciative
not only of your book but also of the
way you ran Al Gore's campaign
- it wasn't your fault Betty lost so I'm
also wondering what do you think about
Al Gore is a candidate for 2020 Thanks
well thank you miss Barbara and thank
you for your kind words you know I don't
know about 2020 right now my focus is on
the election in Alabama I'm on my way to
Alabama I'm going to Auburn I'm a LSU
Tiger I'm going to visit the Auburn
Tigers in a few weeks I'm also concerned
about a we have a race in Georgia
it's a runoff that's one in Atlanta and
I'm going to help my friend next week in
there so I'm gonna think about 2020 and
probably 2019 right now 2018 is really
going to be a very important year for
Democrats and this is this is what I
want to tell all Americans not just
Democrats but all Americans you have a
right to vote you have a right to run
for office you have a right to be
engaged you don't have to just take it
from Washington any other place you go
out there and own your power go out
there and register to vote go out there
get involved and make a difference
that's what I would encourage people do
Barbara not worry about one candidate
just worry about the future of our
democracy and protecting it from foreign
meddling and interference in the future
from North Carolina Republican line
David you're next I David how are you
doing I'm doing good it's good to hear
from somebody from North Carolina hi let
me preface what I'm saying I think
you're you're a Democrat hack but I love
you I love the fact that you are you
have come out and said that something
that everybody thought you want to get
the Clintons off the playing field and I
you know you were the one that brought
up the Willie Horton thing and can I can
I answer you now my friend yes sir yes
ma'am all right boo
here's his Donna 101 I wanted more than
any American probably just like Bill
Clinton just like others I wanted to win
in 2016 I want a hill
Clinton to be present in the United
States had she won I probably still
would have continued my activism I am a
grassroot activist I've been involved in
politics since the age of nine Steve
mentioned Al Gore but I've worked on a
lot of presidential campaigns senatorial
congressional campaigns state and local
campaigns so yes you could call me a
hack but last year the country was
hacked and that's why I selected the
title this book
I do believe David that whenever there
is injustice in society whenever there
are people who are being harmed whenever
there are people whose rights have been
trampled with it is my job in the job of
every American to stand up and to speak
out and to express his or her opinions
that is something that as Americans we
may disagree with but the but the true
nature of our country our democracy is
civility and I also believe David that
we should be civil with one another I
get attacked some time from Democrats
because I reach out to Republicans I
reach out because you know what if I
thought the Democratic Party had all of
the answers and by the way I think we
have most of them I would go home and
say fine just look just elect Democrats
but sometime you hear from the other
side of something you may hear and
understand from the other side and I
think we should listen to one another
and not just be Democrats or Republicans
we need to come back together as
Americans let me put this is a pure
hypothetical but with Roy Moore's name
on the ballot and if the Republicans do
put up a write-in effort for Luther
strange what does that mean for Doug
Jones in Alabama I would hope that mr.
Jones will continue to campaign on the
issues that matter to the people of
Alabama he is talking about jobs he's
talking about education he's talking
about healthcare Roy Moore is talking
about you know what he did I did not do
some 20 years ago Roy Moore four years
ago that's correct
Roy Moore was a district attorney he
held a lot of power these young people
were probably afraid of him scared to go
up and talk to talk about what was
happening to them
he should be respectful of them John
McCain say that what he did was diss if
he did it was disqualifying
I agree if the Republicans want to put
in the right in right on but I tell you
Doug Jones is the way I would go in
Alabama Katrina is joining us from
Castro Valley California Democrats line
with Donna Brazile her latest book hacks
by the way we should point out your
other book
cooking with grease stirring the pots in
American politics well see I have a
history of stirring things up you know
my nickname I'm also putting a book is
trouble I got that nickname from Rahm
Emanuel the mayor of Chicago and I try
to live up to it
Katrina you are next go ahead please
good morning Steve and miss Brazil I
think you have to say I have to say it
is a thrill and an honor to speak with
you I'm so excited I'm going to try to
not get goofy here and first of all I
like say congratulations on your book
thank you ma'am I hope you read it it's
a great book a respect for a book
signing so you could sign it for me and
maybe take a quick vote it was I was I
was in San Francisco just this past I
was there on Thursday night at the
Commonwealth Club I look forward to
coming to Oakland barbara lee is a great
friend and i know a lot of people in
northern california I would love to come
back if you'd welcome any time at any
time day or night 24/7 I appreciate you
and I think you did a great job on the
campaign I watched the whole thing like
I was on it like a laser let me just sum
up what I think about the election okay
since 2015 we know that we've known
what's gone on gone on okay it's not
wasn't a fair election and I think we
should redo it right isn't that what
kids do when it's not a fair it's not a
fair wasn't they're both both sides
didn't play fair well I thank you so
much and I want to just say this I I
would hope that we take some lessons
from 2016 and that is as Americans
whenever we hear the word hacks we
should take we should take notice that
someone is trying to interfere someone
is trying to influence influence us one
of the characters I mentioned in the
book he called me just about every day
to give me an idea what the active
measures would be to destabilize our
democracy destabilize and call it a
question our election and
that's why I believe the onus is also on
the president he needs to acknowledge
what happened last year he needs to
convene a bipartisan commission to study
ways in which we can protect our country
in the future I've seen that happen in
Germany with their election and France
with their election recently in Austria
and so many other countries and
Netherlands we need to take a page from
my own book from 2016 and strengthen our
democracy chapter 12 I am NOT Patsy the
slave explained well I believe that when
Donald Trump said what the hell you have
to lose that was my wake-up call that
this was going to be a very close
election when he said that I want to do
more than just write a column which I
did I wanted to fight back I tried to
hire people and in some cases not even
hyerim they were wanted to come and work
for free and Brooklyn refused I had to
get on a conference call with Brooklyn I
call him Brooklyn the high command of
Brooklyn was my way of saying that I
would have call up to talk to Robert
Mook I go through the intermediaries
between me and Robby Mook and say I need
to bring on people who could help me
expand the vote I was very worried that
the Obama coalition did not get enough
attention and that's why I say I'm not
patch to the slate Patsy and you know
the analogy here is that as a woman I
wanted to make my own decisions I did
not want someone in the headquarters in
Brooklyn making decisions of how the DNC
the Democratic National Committee which
nominated Hillary I did not work for
Hillary I did not work for the campaign
I worked I was a volunteer for the DNC
and my obligations were not only to the
offices of the Democratic National
Committee but my obligation was to the
rank and file and those donors and
supporters on the Republican line David
is next Watertown South Dakota good
morning Wow David yeah good morning it's
been very interesting now listening to
you I think you should run under the
Democratic ticket you impress me more
than any other Democrat I've heard but I
agree that the Russians meddled with our
elections just like the United
State has meddled with every election in
every country in the world for years but
I don't think the Russians try to elect
Trump when they already had their hooks
in into mrs. Clinton and you know when
you claim that other countries meddle in
elections Obama actively campaigned for
one of the candidates and the British
election and he did everything he could
to defeat Netanyahu it's just it's just
the way the world politics are but you
have really impressed me and if you run
for president as a Democrat you would be
the first Democrat I've ever before
thank you very well thank you David and
thank you for your kind words a lot of
the people of South Dakota let me just
say this my mother taught us that two
wrongs don't make a right I've heard
that argument as well that you know the
United States have meddled in elections
perhaps so and I know of some occasions
that I've read that and witnessed at but
I am referring to our democracy our
country that we came under attack in
2016 look in 2008 when the Chinese tried
to hack into both McCain and President
Obama's campaign the Justice Department
went to those officials and said here's
what's happening in our case it was
delayed for months in large part because
we had a contractor who were maintained
in our system and we didn't know but
once we started taking remediation we
did the very best job of trying to
remove them so that they would not
interfere meddle
we've seen now with the social media
campaign and we've heard from others how
how much the Russians were actively
engaged in sowing discord and creating
distrust and yes they tried to destroy
Secretary Clinton they had they wanted
to destroy her credibility they want to
destroy her political party her platform
everything and one way they sought to do
it was to sow discord between the
Sanders campaign in the Clinton campaign
and that's why I said when I found the
cancer I wanted to get rid of it because
I didn't want to have any you know any
excuse out there why Secretary Clinton
wasn't
in a strong campaign to win the
presidency I want to come back to the
book in a moment Donna Brazile but the
Ninth Ward in Louisiana what's it like
today first of all we're mourning the
loss of fats Domino's lists you know
Blueberry Hill I love that man I love
Fats Domino
you know it's hard you can sing the song
I know I know I walk into New Orleans I
mean you know it's a little kid my honey
Dale lived in the Ninth Ward and we used
to go by Fats Domino house because you
can see over the fence and his paint
piano I mean he was such a good guy that
he would come outside and give us candy
when I think of the Ninth Ward I think
of fats Domino's I think of the music
the rhythm it's coming back you know
what any hurricane it takes a while for
the recovery efforts to begin I served
on the Louisiana Recovery Authority
under the governor Kathleen Blanco we
wanted to rebuild stronger and safer not
just our levees but also to lift the
houses up above ground so that people
would have a chance to survive any
storms I want to say something about
Houston I've been to Texas twice I want
to say something about Puerto Rico I
haven't been back to Puerto Rico but we
have to help those people they're our
citizens it will take time for them to
rebuild their lives to rebuild their
homes and to get back into their
communities as Americans we're going to
invest in making those places safer and
stronger but we should not forget them
because it takes a while for you to come
back from a storm Louisiana's back next
year we're celebrating our 300th
anniversary I'm on the try Centennial
committee we're excited about the future
of Louisiana we're excited about what's
happening now State on the John bel that
woods and I am proud to call Louisiana
my home and I love my Mayor Mitch
Landrieu this is his last year in office
and I just want to say to him thank you
for your service
he has been an incredible voice of
change in this in the great city of New
Orleans
our guest is Donna Brazile the book is
titled hacks and malcolm you're next
from McMinnville Tennessee Democrats
line Wow Malcolm you with us yeah
question for Donald oh no no what you
know would you suggest the special
counsel
Check Into Hilary Stowe no sir let me
just say this knowing what I know what
they did was legal you can set up a
joint fundraising agreement you can have
a memo Memorandum of Understanding
between one staff to another staff you
can you can file you on FEC reports
there's nothing illegal about what
occurred it was in my judgment I did not
like it because in an unethical because
I couldn't do my job as chair I had to
get permission
sometimes permission to even write a
press release I was told what I could
and could not say and so some time I
didn't say anything so no I think I
think Secretary Clinton ran a very it's
as far as I can tell they were in a
vibrant campaign after all they got
three million more votes than the
present occupant you know I left and
tell people Steve that every time the
winner of the electoral college lose the
popular vote Donna goes to Harvard I've
been up at the Kennedy School
Shorenstein Center for media politics
and policy and one of the things I'm
focusing on is how do we prevent the
hacking of our election again I mean
this book is not just about the Clintons
and the Clinton campaign this book is
about our democracy and how do we
protect it I also have some common-sense
solutions on how every Americans should
protect their own identity how they
should have two-step verification on
their phone systems I mean you're out
there yakking and yakking and
instagramming everybody and snapchatting
away and you're not protecting yourself
with a 2-step verification process
change your passwords change it often I
mean so I I get a little technical in
the book because the hacker house those
wonderful Americans who came to our
rescue I talk about their service to our
country they were able to help us fight
the russian midland but it was tough
throughout the entire process start to
finish how long did it take for you to
write the book I had help I had helped
by a remarkable woman a writer Danielle
Martin she put a mic she put a tape
recorder in front of me and boy was that
authority to relive the campaign it took
9 weeks I was under a tight deadline and
I waited people kept back to me about
the time and I I assumed that someone in
the Clinton campaign
I beg Robbie to come to our future
forums I assumed that they were
indeed right to post-mortem and when I
didn't see a post-mortem on the hackin
plus a post-mortem on what was going on
internally in the dnc I decided to write
this book did you read what happened by
Hillary Clinton let me tell you it was a
good read I hope she'll sign my my book
one day I mean she'll sign her book and
I'll sign my book to her it was great
book it was historical it was
biographical but also I thought she also
gave us some great strong
recommendations on how to treat women in
the future especially women candidates
and that's another reason why I'm so
delighted that so many women are
thinking about running for office next
year it's a great book the subtitle is
the inside story of the break-ins and
breakdowns that put Donald Trump in the
White House and from the book you write
the following the 2016 campaign the
convention the election had shattered
long-standing relationships leaving old
friends wary of one another this is more
than the burnout and dejection that
follows a crushing loss the Russian
dirty cyber tricks that were still
coming to light had left everyone scared
and scarred yeah oh God it was um Steve
I've been involved in a lot of campaigns
I've managed Al Gore's campaigning down
in the beautiful city of Nashville
Tennessee I've been called a lot of
things I've been attacked many many many
times working in politics personally
attack I've apologized for attacking
others everything you can name but when
you have a foreign government actively
seeking to destroy and discredit your
candidate actively seeking to destroy
your political party actively seeking to
weaken your democratic institutions
which includes the media oh yeah it
wasn't it wasn't nice I mean they
influenced our campaign the journalists
out there and I want to caution them
once again the journalists took every
every leak as if it was the gospel truth
as if it came from the book of Joshua or
it was it came down from the mountain
they never questioned it
they used it every day to further so
discard into our election to further
weaken Secretary Clinton to further
weaken and and and it led to the
harassment of individuals within the
Democratic Party donors ordinary
citizens who had their
information on our website because they
saw the white house tour all of a sudden
their information was out in the public
and so I believed that this was this
this was a crisis moment for our our
country and yet on November 9th the day
after the election everybody gets into
party mode for Donald Trump and on this
on the Clinton side and the Democrats
we're all morning and nobody's thinking
about our democracy that's what scared
me
you called Anderson Cooper a boo my boo
yeah that's an affectionate term from a
southerner how many do you have several
I got hundreds of boos and a but-but-but
I have to tell you my book is also
dedicated to my booty booty booty wife's
that was my doggy
chippie gumdrop my Pomeranian I'm miss
boo boo boo boo was chip chip was was
not just a dog but he was a dog of all
dogs I said I used to say the chip was a
cross between Luther Vandross and George
Clooney
he had Luther Vandross voice and George
Clooney's look I mean I mean that's what
I think George would look like if he was
a dog but I'm not calling him a dog
because he's one of my favorite actors
along with Denzel Washington where was
this picture taken back in 2015 that was
taken on Capitol Hill and as you can
tell I had on some CNN makeup but that's
my pootie right look how happy chimp
love to watch Anderson Cooper I know he
loved and he loves Rachel Maddow
he had favorites and trust me there were
some people when I put him on [ __ ] with
like mommy here we go to sleep I'm I
talked to my dog I did I had I had a
loving relationship with my animal and I
can't wait to I can't wait to meet chip
again chip was just a beautiful dog I
miss him very much
we're gonna go to kid I'm just letting
it we're gonna carry at Homestead
Florida Donna Brazile good morning hi
miss troubled children woman but I bet
you've known a lot of women that cause
trouble I bet you've known some women
that stirred the pot I bet you have no
problem getting in trouble with the
right kind of woman that's who I am
Oh
copy and anything but let's listen it
takes a brave marine a real courage to
do what you're doing you know the come
over you know c-span that and I love the
guy that c-span they do great work you
know a baby like give them all your
applause and they're they're just one
but it shows courage were you to come on
this go this just TV and say what you
say well thank you carry response well
it took courage for Esther and the Bible
to go to the King and see if I perish I
perish but I'm going to save my people
it took courage for Harriet Tubman to go
back and forth to get people out of
bondage it took courage for what Nelson
Mandela do what dr. King did it's
occurred to what Mother Teresa it's not
it's it's about the courage of your
convictions and if you believe that
something is unjust you should speak out
but more importantly if you believe in
freedom and equality of all people and
support diverse and and inclusion you
speak up I let me tell you I was telling
my colleagues and students up at Harvard
last week I said if you think this got
me in trouble
imagine being a student at LSU in the
late 70s and you're calling for a
holiday for dr. King which I later
worked on or you calling for the freedom
of Nelson Mandela which I later worked
on I mean that got me in trouble
I've been trouble on my life but I've
been in good trouble there's good
trouble I'm good trouble we'll go to
mark joining us from st. Paul Minnesota
Republican line you are on the air with
Donna Brazile no thank you
I have three brief but related questions
number one miss Brazil you indicate in
your book that you closed the blinds to
your office because you were afraid of
sniper fire I guess I'm wondering who
exactly did you think would be shooting
at you and what would it be a foreign
power or domestic powers such as maybe
the Clinton machine number two said
there's a theory that set rich was the
hacker where the person who leaked the
hack emails I'm wondering what your
thoughts would be with regard to that
allegation and number three I'm
wondering if you have any theories with
regard to
who might have killed Seth rich let me
just say this sir when I got back to the
DNC headquarters after the brief and I
mentioned in the book how scared I was I
want to go to the the Pentagon I didn't
want to go back to the DNC I wanted the
DNC to be closed down with yellow tape
around it and later in the book I also
described how we got word that the DNC
might have to close its office and I
look for an alternative office so this
was not the ordinary kind of campaign
where people just call you and say one
or two bad things but this is a campaign
where you guys suspicious packages you
got all kinds of threats you you you're
getting incoming from everywhere and
you're trying to do your very best as I
did to protect the staff and
infrastructure at the DNC we made some
important security changes to our office
space our physical office base our
security so people just couldn't walk in
off the streets we did a lot of prudent
steps that that I believe helped to save
us now you know I get really touchy
about Seth Richard because as I
mentioned earlier he's a patriot he was
a loyal member of the Democratic
National Committee and that he worked
faithfully to honor part of who we are
and that is the right of every American
to participate in election process and
he helped to create along with many many
others I will vote calm which provided
valuable resources to those who did not
know what their polling center if they
were registered about a 1 to get more
information about the candidates what
regards to these conspiracy about Seth
rich they are baloney and we owe it to
his parents Joel and Mary who I know
very well I spoke at a synagogue
I know exactly whose authority was to
the DNC he was part of our team and I
can tell you that Seth rich should be
honored for being a great American
somebody who cared to make a difference
and all of these conspiracy theories
honor his parents wishes drop it let us
find the person or the individuals who
murdered Seth rich but let us stop let
us stop destroying his good name he was
he was a friend I gave he was my kid you
can ask the governor watch
the state I was out there with jay
inslee and his wife Trudy upon learning
Anna Navarro and I were together upon
learning a South murder I had to call in
to the DNC office to comfort people to
comfort my colleagues but then I had to
cry myself I couldn't stop crying
because Seth was one of my kids and when
you hurt somebody that you love when
somebody you love is hurt you you you
stand up for them and Wow I wasn't his
mother or father Joel and Mary I know
them I've I've had plenty of time with
them they are great people they are
still suffering along with his brother
Aaron and they deserve one day where we
honor their child and not try to destroy
his name as you know the Fox News
Channel and Sean Hannity in particular
did a series of programs on Seth Rich
that was wrong a lot of questions wrong
look we should answer I've seen the
police report we should answer we should
find out and I know the Metropolitan
Police Department continues this is an
active case there's a reward for anyone
who knows anything about Seth murder but
let us not what I call tarnish his name
Seth was a great person and the lies
that are being told sometime like
whether where did this come from
I mean the lies Seth worked he was
honorable and that was nothing found on
his computers the stuff I have read I'm
like where did getting the information
from the first person I wanted to
protect when I walked into that building
when I came back into that building was
set I wish we had more life seth rich
more more young people who are willing
to go out there and work for democracy
he wanted to see Hillary Clinton in the
White House as well so god bless UCF god
bless you our last call is from Missouri
Democrats line bettan go ahead please
hey Donna I was good to talk with you I
just have a few questions about the
timing of the book and this may seem to
Democrats like it it's a way for you to
make money off this book at a time when
it's like beating a dead horse after
this election it's just a tough time for
Democrats so I feel like are you trying
to work with Democrats to come up with
solutions for or last election that's
you know came up with these results as
far as you know long lines at polls and
the voter turnout and hurting everyone
towards one tenth it such as Hillary
Clinton there was no there was no
opposition to her and the Democrats
distance it takes to get to polls
reduction of early voting things like
that voter suppression by law Thank You
Ben we'll get a response well first of
all thank you for your great question I
think the best time to talk about the
previous election is when we're one year
out when it's still fresh in our
memories this is about you know trying
to ensure that we have a stronger
political party in the future as well as
a stronger democracy that can withstand
the kind of foreign interference and
attacks so I would hope that many of my
friends and colleagues who have not
enjoyed my caught on quote timing would
understand that this was about trying to
heal wounds not open wounds but to heal
them we have to properly heal the only
way to heal something that's been
infected is to address it and dress
address all of it so this is again this
is just Donna Brazile version Hillary
has written a book Bernie has written a
book Joe Biden book is coming out soon
there are so many other books that will
talk about the the 2016 campaign I hope
when the reader finished my book they'll
they'll see that not only am i still out
there trying to help the Democratic
Party but I want to help the country
become stronger to come more actively
engage in protecting our democracy and
yes sir I agree with you we have to
ensure that there are no blocks or
hurdles or obstacles to any American
you know participating and and the right
to vote voting it's the lifeblood of our
democracy and thank you for your time
and and thank you for your great
questions as well the book is titled
hacks - the inside story of the
break-ins and breakdowns that put Donald
Trump in the White House down to Brazil
what's next for you I'm still at Harvard
my report is due soon it's about
strengthening our democracy in the
future I'm looking forward to going back
to Georgetown next semester I got a lot
on my plate you know as always but my
most important the most important thing
I try to do each and every day in my
life is to think about all of the young
people like myself who got involved in
in politics at an early age I want to
help them get get a seat at the table
even if we have to bring some folding
chairs Donna Brazile always a pleasure
to have you here please come back again
I will like so much thank you